[Music]
there's just something about
the sound
the speed oh
that is fast and of course
the savagery had a shot and this time he
does deliver oh
nifty that is disgusting look where the
bombs drop now as well
it's the most iconic gun in
counter-strike
and the only specific weapon in all of
esports to have a position
named after it the op is a feared and
respected weapon in counter-strike
its mere existence changes how players
navigate the map
in a game where spray patterns mean so
much
and movement is the death of
marksmanship there's one
stewie can he do it can he do it now
stop by carrick and phase stay in this
it almost feels unfair that there exists
something as simple straightforward
and sublime as the op to think that you
can not be looking and just do this
and kill two guys he's like what the
hell man it's like it shouldn't it
shouldn't be fair
the op isn't just a sniper rifle it's a
living breathing art form
a brush that gamers have been using to
paint beautiful bloody portraits
for nearly two decades it's known love
oh guardian he gets two there's still
more to go though that i must pop the
bomb the peaks come in the guardian
will not stop one more to go and
guardian
gets them hate at the very start but
oscar oh no he misses the city
and everything in between there was a
lot of things that i was doing
and that i could not do anymore so i had
to find new stuff i had to
to play a bit different in fact it's
because of its tumultuous history
that the op remains one of the most
infamous and influential instruments of
digital death
ever created this is its story
[Music]
the arctic warfare police also known as
the awp
or op like its real world counterpart is
a high-powered
bolt-action rifle equipped with a
long-range scope
and while it's made appearances in a
variety of shooters it's most famous for
playing an integral
role in counter-strike to this day the
off remains
the definition of high-risk high reward
it offers tremendous damage output
incredible armor penetration
and perfect hit scan precision the
trade-off
is that it's slow to operate difficult
to handle in close quarters
and most importantly needs to be
manually reloaded
after every single shot
it's also one of the most expensive
weapons in counter-strike
and it's usually in a team's best
economic interest to run only one at a
time
but that hasn't stopped it from becoming
both a fan favorite and a meta staple
in every iteration of counter-strike
well
i mean imagine cs without the orb right
i feel like some players would be really
bad and some players would be like
way better than they are like imagine
faze nico if he
the only thing that kills him is an orb
that guy doesn't lose an air jewel man
so
the reason for this is simple it's the
only weapon in the game that can kill an
enemy with a single shot to the head or
torso
regardless of whether they're wearing
armor because of this the op
is a weapon where in terms of raw
mechanical skill
the floor is actually quite low you
literally have to just right click
and then move your hand a tiny bit and
left click and you'll kill people like
if you're aiming in the right place
you'll kill people you know
uh anyone can all anybody could up like
it's really easy
but the ceiling is unbelievably high i
think to
to be with oprah you have to master it
you have to
know everything about it like how to
quiz up or to
like your movements also have to be
pretty smooth whereas most of
counter-strike's weapons are hindered by
player movement
susceptible to crosshair expansion and
shoot along specially designed spray
patterns
the op offers a way to circumvent all of
that
to shoot someone one time from nearly
anywhere
through nearly anything and remove them
from the round in the blink of an eye
can be a make or break moment they can't
do anything more to like nerf it you
know because the gun's broken like it is
it's [ __ ] like fully fully [ __ ]
to think that you can not be looking and
just do this
and kill two guys he's like what the
hell man it's like it shouldn't it
shouldn't be fair
but like like you said it has to be in
the game because every game has one um
yeah it's just it's very very broken and
anyone can use it
so that's like the most annoying part
like you can die to the worst player
and you're like he has an off like it
doesn't matter
like if you die to an ak you're like
you're probably out in me
so yeah it could be annoying sometimes
this means that nothing
not cover not [ __ ] movement not even
protective plates
can provide sanctuary from that weapon's
wrath the op
is like the boogeyman of counter-strike
in addition to being the most powerful
weapon
it's the one whose presence inspires the
most fear
from a strategic standpoint the op is
one of the objects around which nearly
the entirety of counter-strike revolves
it closes off bomb sites shuts down
sight lines and forces enemy teams into
something of an ultimatum
avoid it like the plague or counter it
at all costs msl
how's the maneuver with balls with me
[Applause]
unbelievable if you look at us for
example i like to buy it a lot but we
also have set strategies where you don't
need an all
and the orb also has certain limitations
right you're slower with the movement
speed it's harder to insert bump side
with it
and and a lot of our strategies also
revolves around can the opponents have a
knob
you ask the question how important is it
to know those kind of things and the
economy plays a huge part
in what things you can do can you run
specific areas without smoking it
smoking them or do you have to use a lot
of utility to get there
i think they're always very instrumental
for counter-strike most importantly the
ops incredible strength stems from the
fact that it is in essence
a point and click deletion tool so
players started thinking
if the op is this good why restrict it
to long range use
why not use it all the time good call
and it's dissolving as well flash dodges
nails it hits pronounce
it wrapped over to his left second shot
from kenny they're not going fast enough
rack through that second door put
pressure on he goes into a pistol and
gets
two it was from this realization this
innovation
that opping and the culture thereof was
born
from wall bangs but he will have another
crack
at a shot and this time he does deliver
oh nifty
that is disgusting look where the bombs
drop now as well
to quick scopes kenny almost oh
what to no scopes
bopping quickly established itself as
the sexiest most stylish and most
skillful way
to dispose of one's enemies as well as
the most sublime
and like all warrioristic ways it wasn't
long before it attracted a loyal
constituency
devotees who are known both then and now
as offers when i feel
when i feel the op power or how to say
that that's when
i want to buy it but now people tell me
to buy it a bit more
because they actually think i am good
with it and that i
yeah get a lot of map control and all
that stuff
on the one hand oper is a positional
term it refers to the player on a team
who's been entrusted to handle something
as singular and skill intensive as the
awk
but it's also a term of art a title that
players identify with at almost
a spiritual level running the op is a
big responsibility
and it's pretty standard for teams to
bestow it upon someone who isn't just
good with it
but has devoted every waking second of
their life
to mastering it so yeah what i do
basically it's uh
200 kills hope each days
also why don't you kill ak and
50 m4 it's fair to say that no two
offers are exactly
alike and that each one is contributed
to the advancement of the craft in their
own
special way but as with all crafts
opping wouldn't be what it is today
without its giants
those practitioners who didn't advance
it as much as they revolutionized it
in 1.6 the most iconic of such players
was igor
marcoloth markolov a ukrainian legend
who helped pioneer a playstyle that
in addition to placing a heavy emphasis
on entry fragging
was known for being highly aggressive
the next generation of noteworthy operas
was spearheaded by a group of 1.6 and
source players
who would go on to have even more
illustrious careers in cs go
jasper j w vexel gabriel fall in toledo
latislav guardian kovacs and perhaps the
single most famous opera of all time
kenny kenny s shrub but once again this
is the most important position pretty
much on the a side pngx not going to
give it up without a fight and it's
going to come down to kenny s with the
awp
1v3 we can see where he's looking now
just gets the shot barely on msl
finds the second one yes with the no
scope
despite having made a name for himself
and source it was in cs go
where kenny s became a full-fledged
divinity
in addition to his all too famous flick
shots kenny became renowned for his
tendency to land pixel perfect peaks
whilst moving in on already established
defenders it's going to be the old patel
again jw versus kenny and
kenny comes out on top jw was one pixel
away with that shot and look at titan
he also demonstrated an inhuman ability
to dominate in quarters that most operas
would classify
as too close for comfort comes kenny s
oh my god kenny s with three insane
kills
and he has time wait are you telling me
he's going to win the round has he got
time
yeah he's got time unbelievable by early
2015 the french phenom had become
renowned for having perfected
a hyper aggressive in your face style of
opping the likes of which the world
had never seen he was someone who could
play very close he could
move very quickly with the op he could
hit no scopes he was constantly quick
peeking and quick scoping
that movement mechanic was taken out
quite significantly
in fact it was due to kenny's unique
awping style and how
influential it became that in march 2015
valve did the unthinkable they took the
op
the crown jewel of counter-strike and
nerfed it
in the patch released on the 31st of
march the op
and auto snipers as well they're not
particularly relevant
in the competitive scene but the the op
was nerfed in as much as
movement while scoped was reduced
in what has since become recognized as
one of the most controversial updates in
cs go history
valve lowered the value of the op scoped
movement speed making it so that
attacking offers were at a significant
disadvantage to defending ones
here he comes once again the first base
is a trend he's going to hit the ground
there is cold
oh wow that's jumping double from cold
what is it going on right now how does
he do this
corner safely velocity with your play
unthinkable scenes there on the b
apartments the fallout for kenny the
community
and counter-strike at large was horrific
the update essentially forced operas
everywhere to relearn
their weapon of choice and take an
entirely new approach to angles that
they've been practicing since 1.6 and
source
i got hit like even in my motivation
i was like damn why didn't do that that
that's so unfair for me because
i actually felt like they did it for me
they did it because of me
that's not necessarily true but that's
how i felt
for better or for worse valve forced
operas into an ultimatum
adapt and in turn evolve or be
superseded
30 seconds to plant therefore he's going
to drop a smoky spot dennis just for a
moment oh he hits the shot
the bomb is down on the train now fox
has to go and collect that and neo
is going to try to make this happen with
his awp he's got the smoke there on his
left that is giving him a bit of extra
space
and he finds the shot
[Applause]
kenny did eventually adapt and it wasn't
long before he was once again
putting on the kinds of performances
that we'd come to expect
trying to talk trying to find something
through to smoke or he's gonna find fox
as well he is not giving this one
up he's gonna push through the window
indeed he's coming through the smoke
rain goes down as well
only imaginative to fight now he will
finally put an
end to this madness and yet despite
finally earning a major victory at cluj
napoca in november 2015
he never managed to re-establish himself
as the godly
untouchable opera he once was i mean of
course
he was like the best player individually
i guess
so but the thing the thing was that
including myself and probably many many
others as well was that you started to
you started to fear him you know because
you started to think that he is
god-like or whatever like you can't kill
him like i think that that's
that was something that he took
advantage of
very very much at that time
and i think that is the biggest
difference to now people don't really
sure have been in a slump and all that
but the most the
most important factor right now i would
say is that people don't
fear him the same way to this day many
regard the change as having been
unjustified
given that there had only been a handful
of competitors who were capable of
carrying the gun
to such absurd heights in the first
place he's drawing point right back well
it might be helpful if he played more
than 20 hours
because his team started dying don't
don't change the off guys
kenny s it's [ __ ] his fault in there
at the time of its release many feared
that the update had nerfed the weapon
beyond
recognition and that it would mark the
death of the op
altogether needless to say they were
wrong
it's been four years since the infamous
off nerf and in that time
not a whole lot has changed the op isn't
what it used to be but it's still the
strongest weapon in cs go
you just can't be as obscenely
aggressive with it yeah i think it's
become
less aggressive since the nerf back in
the days
back in the days you could peek into
angles way more aggressively because you
had a higher movement speed
so for sure the op has been a bit more
passive these days
but still i feel like there's a lot of
flexibility in how you want to play the
orb
and for the most part people have
regarded that as a good thing
do you remember before they did the
update can you expect this like there
was too much
yeah one guy oh there were stars modern
kings like all average avps could do the
same thing you know not to the same
extent the skinny is good but it was no
good against google you could you could
abuse it for sure
whichever side you fall on one thing is
certain the nerf made oping
harder and forced existing operas to
become significantly more strategic in
their approach
i think csgo nowadays on the current
meta we're playing
people are always challenging for
information like no back in the days you
could trick
players by throwing some nades there and
then you would say hey now that they
lost this part of the map
we can move forward with this thing but
with the way players are playing right
now
being so aggressive in terms of
collecting the z-fo you can really
get tricked by thinking they don't have
something but actually they have it
because they went to check it with a
flash or they just double picked it or
they just
really took their risk to find what's
going on there and that changed the game
a lot so
you really have to be a little bit
aggressive developer nowadays
to kind of play on this meta where
information is important every time
but it also gave birth to a new more
dynamic generation of offers
players who were forced to work twice as
hard as their predecessors in order to
achieve the same result
open styles is it can be annoying
sometimes for me because i'm like
normally well i used to be like an
aggressive offer
get in your face but then i realized
everyone was really smart
at the top level and i just died all the
time so i stopped doing that
so yeah it's really hard for me now
because i'm trying to find my style
because i don't really have one
i'm kind of just doing what i'm told to
do and that's it which is like really
frustrating for myself because i've
always been the dominant one
the nerf sent opping into something of
an existential crisis
and for up-and-comers this was somewhat
terrifying
but it was also liberating since there
was no longer a single accepted style
that everyone was trying to imitate
the next generation of giants were free
to create their own i
in the beginning i had kind of an
identity crisis because
fallen and kenny s were the hot thing at
that point they were the best players
but they were so
fast paced and close combat auburns and
i that's not my style
so i remember looking at the best operas
and thinking i'm not
that type of author and i had to create
some of my own style that would work for
the team but also for me
and and that's where i kind of got idea
of the style that i'm playing right now
nikolai device wreaths is currently
considered to be one of the best and
most original operas
in the world and just find something
weird that a straws can't handle
another great pick for device and
another opening kill
and he's gonna go for the follow-up he's
blind magisk has got an eight kill
again the round is over and why not
continue challenging
you're on fire device shuts him down
four kills in banana
the reason for devices sustained success
isn't because he's aggressive flashy and
unpredictable
on the contrary he's developed a style
of hopping that's almost hyper defensive
yeah we have one now yeah we've we've
definitely got one
device covering as naf tries to retreat
from the smoke he's gonna take that kill
following up on twist and just
completely decimating the incoming
offense here for team liquid nitro and
taco
there's absolutely no way through oh my
god the flick is so quick
but it's precisely because he's so
calculating cautious and risk-averse
that the danish superstar is able to
consistently outshine his opponents
that's kind of when they've fallen into
a trap and astralis
they always have those back-up plans and
they also have device
the man to miss the beast as he pops off
ben three kills found
four kills device once the enemy oh
device
has decimated them he's also an opera
who unlike most of the weapons greatest
wielders
never wanted to op in the first place
basically ever since i remember like i
recall cs from when i was younger i was
always playing a rifle and i was kind of
fast-paced and so
so on then danny joined us as a coach in
the start of 2016
sonic and he basically
did the same at that point we didn't
have a an opera it was kind of fluent
me cajun and kerrigan would switch it up
between us
and he said we need a we need an uber
and
he helped me a lot at that point like
compared me to sunday which is a 1.6
danish legend he was also a rifler and
transitioned into being an all-time
great opera
and i kind of went through the same
thing device was and
in many ways still is a rifler at heart
and it's because of this
that he's managed to become an offer who
dominates both on account of his
passivity
and his hybridity if you look at a team
like australis they're probably the best
in the world
and they only really use the sniper on
the ct side
device rarely buys it in the t side
maybe on one or two out of the seven
maps
he like buys it consistently otherwise
he only buys it if if another team is
like bullying them
this is just a partial buy now for navi
saving himself about two grand
he just out or device at long range of a
deagle
opposite device is the absurdly
aggressive
they're right there both of them in
front of simple creeping in he's going
to get one that i shot two and oh my god
game breakingly accurate simple there
with the awp
taking down rain first next in line is
soul of meister the flick is saying oh
my god
simple and altogether unrivaled
simple see double smoke's in the same
place they're simple just jumping
casually into the side he's going to
fall down again
what is this place from simple are you
serious what is that you can't do that
simple that's not allowed this is not
fpl
this is a major arguably the single most
talented player to ever live
alexander simple castiliev is a
ukrainian prodigy who took a post nerf
op and managed to replicate if not
supersede
kenny s levels of aggression falls back
after the first he's alone
slip shot cavalier he tries to peak it
again and he will
he absolutely will half human half
machine looking straight through the
lens
simple finds around again navi simple
doesn't do
safe smart or sensible he does
the unthinkable down into a one-on-one
good trades but it's simple and he's
already here
right outside smoke gonna go off simple
on the other side he pulls out the
pistol he's got the p250
close range it's a one-shot nitro he's
got a triple he fakes it once and just
goes to check the window this is all
about timing nitro does have a bottle of
another smoke so it could be really
rough or simple to actually get through
this he's going to throw the awp
oh my god what is happening
simple sheer unadulterated belligerence
makes him the antithesis
device in virtually every way they are
both
in their own way the best opera in the
world each for entirely
different reasons if you look for a
device for example he's a player
that often is only taking the smart duos
and has a very strong game in terms of
understanding
what's safe for him what's not safe and
he's taking every single opportunity he
has to bring the advantage to his team
but they look for other helpers for
example you look for kenya's you look
for
sometimes simple even sometimes myself
we're willing to take a little bit more
of a risk and in the end you could be
caught caught in the process
but you are challenging the other team a
little bit more and it's
a very different aspect and very
different way of playing we take more
risks
but sometimes we kind of give it away
for the opponent to a little bit of
advantage right
and it's because of this that people
have started to juxtapose them
i'm having it though yeah comfortable is
a strong word when simples in the server
double
and i think a triple my goodness oh baby
a triple simple it's not going down easy
in many ways valve's notorious nerf tor
opting asunder
and as simple and device's opposing
styles have come to show
that's a good thing
it's true that the nerf may have been
unjustified but it also made awping more
interesting
in forcing operas to rethink their craft
the nerf enabled them to inject it with
new life
to carry the thing that counter-strike
loves most into what is quite possibly
its most undefinable and exciting era
yet
awping is and will always be one of the
few things that is the very lifeblood of
esports
where something that feral cerebral
and altogether indomitable simple
does manage the first oh and the second
as well maybe a little bit more could
come with this now
as kadian down the ramp simple is going
to find everything
goes from here well that's for the next
generation
to decide
i don't like having a favorite offer
because
yeah i i'll just go with i'm i'm my
favorite
office
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button